le canton de plaisir s'est agrandi pour
ses élections départementales la commune
de Beynes a rejoint les villes de
Thiverval-Grignon des Clayes-sous-Bois
et de plaisir le secteur représente
désormais un bassin de vie de 57000
habitants le canton de plaisir est à
gauche depuis les élections
départementales de 2004 et l'élection du
socialiste Jean-Michel Gourdon qui a
choisi de ne pas se représenter le PSC
espère conserver sa place à l'assemblée
départementale pour cela Nicolas eu
conseillé d'opposition Clayes-sous-Bois
et Frédéric Evrard plaisir Oise depuis
1999 ont été désignés par leur parti sur
toutes les élections
nationales se canton et les villes
principales que sont ben plaisir et Les
Clayes-sous-Bois vote à gauche donc nous
pouvons penser évidemment que nous
sommes en situation nous pouvons être en
situation favorable après tout tout le
résultat sera en fait fonction de
l'abstention et de la participation pour
conquérir le dont l'Union de la Droite a
mis en place une équipe composée du duo
Joséphine commensberger mer UMP de
plaisir depuis 2012 et de Bertrand
Coquard conseiller municipal udi des
Clayes-sous-Bois je pense que quand on a
la chance d'être élu depuis de
nombreuses années on a effectivement en
main en tout cas
une connaissance qui est une
connaissance qui peut qui peut servir à
la population une proximité aussi
puisque c'est un travail que je fais
depuis de nombreuses années d'être
proche de la population à l'écoute avec
je pense du pragmatisme et aussi du
courage politique il en faut donc je
pense qu'au niveau du département je
peux être peut-être utile dans ce duel
annoncé entre le Parti socialiste et
l'Union de la Droite le Front national
va tenter de créer la surprise troisième
partie du canton en 2011 avec 15% des
voix le FN sera représenté par Eric
Jégou et Estelle et Oliveira Fernandes
le FN est devenu la priorité parce que
c'est une autre voie c'est un c'est la
politique sous un autre angle sous une
bonne gestion et nous on ne fait pas des
promesses en l'air on tient à bien gérer
les choses quand on tracte on est très
très bien accueilli beaucoup de gens
comptent sur nous parce qu'ils
commencent à se rendre compte alors
c'est un petit peu long mais là ça y est
je pense que les gens se rendent compte
qu'on leur ment et que les nos hommes
politiques nos élites ont complètement
abandonné les les Français et les
Yvelinois pour parler plutôt des
départementales mais en fait voilà on a
un petit peu perdu nos hommes politiques
dans ce canton de plaisir trois autres
binômes se présentent le Front de Gauche
est représenté par le duo Maryse
Mézières et Jamel niati la liste Europe
Écologie Les Verts sera menée par Gérard
Lévy et Patricia Charton enfin Fabien
Mettet et Pascal Michard sont sur la
liste debout la France lors des
dernières élections de 2011 le
socialiste Jean-Michel Gourdon l'avait
emporté devant la candidature MP
Véronique côté Millard avec 57% des voix